[Música]
el presidente de Chile Gabriel boric
reforma su gabinete en la víspera de
cumplirse un año de su toma de Posesión
Boris cambia a cinco ministros con el
objetivo declarado de mejorar la
respuesta a las urgencias que tiene el
país
encuentro entre aliados occidentales el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden y
la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula bonder Legend se reunieron en la
casa blanca con la Guerra de Ucrania y
la cooperación comercial en el centro de
la agenda ampliaremos desde Washington
Irán y Arabia Saudita dos rivales
históricos de medio oriente
restablecieron relaciones diplomáticas
volverán a abrir su respectivas
embajadas cerradas en 2016 y reactivan
su acuerdo de cooperación en seguridad
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
Chile porque el presidente Gabriel
borich anunció una esperada reforma de
su gabinete ejecutivo a puertas del
primer aniversario de su toma de
Posesión el mandatario cambió a los
titulares de exteriores Obras Públicas
cultura deportes y ciencia después de
que la cámara de diputados rechazara su
reforma tributaria borich aseguró que la
renovación no se debe a presiones
internas de la coalición de gobierno
sino a la necesidad de contar con
personas con conocimiento de estado para
responder a las demandas del país
precisamente nuestra corresponsal en
Santiago Patricia Luna nos habló de
estas necesidades urgentes a las que
boric hizo referencia
segunda gran reforma de gabinetes por
parte del gobierno de boric que se
convierte así en el que cambia más
ministros en su primer año de gobierno
en torno a como bien dices asegurar el
cumplimiento de las necesidades actuales
de los chilenos estas necesidades han
sido esbozadas en su discurso en el que
también se le sintió
la lamentación de que no se fuera
aprobada la reforma tributaria y hizo
especial hincapié en el tema de las
pensiones no podemos permitirnos otro
fallo en este sentido los chilenos no
pueden esperar más estas serían algunas
de las prioridades también relacionadas
con la educación en la que ha mencionado
la importancia de luchar contra el
absentismo escolar y también mejorar la
calidad y la acceso a la infraestructura
educativa además de otros temas como
puede ser reducir la lista de espera
esto además en un discurso marcado
también por los índices recuperación
económica levemente que se han producido
en este mes en que se redujo un poquito
la inflación uno de los temas que ha
estado en el corazón de los chilenos que
han sufrido fuertemente el alza de
precios por primera vez en tres décadas
de forma muy fuerte en este año y
también los temas de seguridad que
también han sido mencionados por el
presidente en un discurso en el que has
realizado una especie de balance de su
año en el gobierno
cambiamos de información pero
continuamos en América Latina porque
este viernes finalizó en Ciudad de
México la segunda fase de la mesa de
diálogos de paz entre el gobierno de
Colombia y la guerrilla del eln el
ejército de liberación nacional entre
las conclusiones de esta ronda El
Ejecutivo de Petro reconoce el estatus
político del eln como organización
Armada Rebelde y ambas partes mostraron
un optimismo moderado de cara al
objetivo de un acuerdo para el cese el
fuego bilateral recordemos que en 2019
el gobierno de Iván Duque suspendió las
negociaciones con la guerrilla y que la
administración Petro la retomó en 2022
con el auspicio de Cuba Noruega y
Venezuela como países garantes
vamos ahora a Estados Unidos porque el
presidente de Joe biden recibió en la
casa blanca la presidenta de la comisión
europea Úrsula fonter Legend los líderes
de las dos grandes potencias
occidentales abordaron dos grandes temas
por un lado el futuro de su apoyo frente
a la invasión rusa y por otro lado un
nuevo marco de cooperación comercial
para acceder a minerales clave en la
fabricación de vehículos eléctricos y de
otras baterías un mercado dominado en
gran parte por china ahora conectamos
con nuestro corresponsal en Washington a
Cristóbal Vázquez Cristóbal Buenas
tardes para usted en esta cooperación
esta nueva cooperación llegaría luego de
meses de tensiones comerciales entre
ambas potencias desatadas recordemos por
la ley de reducción de la inflación de
biden Sin embargo ahora Wander Legend
aplaudió a esta ley Cómo ha cambiado la
posición europea en este encuentro
además era ya una presión que recibía el
gobierno de Joe biden no solamente por
parte de la presidenta de la comisión
europea sino también por parte del
canciller alemán
y también por parte de el presidente
frasén Emanuel macron Y es que lo que
busca la ley de inflación es
subvencionar energía de la producción de
energía verde en este país la producción
de energía renovable y esto le daría una
ventaja comparativa a empresas
estadounidenses de Cara a empresas
europeas o empresas estadounidenses que
tienen subsidiarias en Europa y esto
haría entonces que muchas empresas que
están en Europa quieran trasladarse a
Estados Unidos por eso la presión de
muchos líderes europeos y visitas del
iese europeo recientemente la casa
blanca para tratar de cierta manera
llegar a un punto a un balance para
evitar que se empiece a desarrollar una
competencia entre occidente entre la
Unión Europea y Estados Unidos para
aumentar esta subvención y pues reducir
el poder que tenga como bloque tanto
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
conjuntamente de Cara a pues eh
contrincantes o competidores como China
y Rusia precisamente hablando de Rusia
pasamos a otro al otro gran tema de la
agenda y es que Washington y Bruselas
han ido prácticamente a la una en su
apoyo a Ucrania qué pistas tenemos del
futuro de esta cooperación militar en el
marco de la otan
hay que Resaltar que en el marco de la
bota en Estados Unidos de lejos sigue
siendo el país que más ayuda militar
brinda a Ucrania y no quiere dejar ese
rol protagónico el gobierno de Joe biden
incluso de cara al presupuesto que
presentó recientemente pues la ayuda y
el presupuesto en defensa aumentó un dos
coma tres por ciento Eso quiere decir
que hay todavía interés de seguir
respaldando no solamente conjuntamente
los esfuerzos que hace la otan en como
miembro de latam Estados Unidos de cara
Ucrania sino que también en estas
visitas pues se sigue planteando sobre
la mesa que es tanto Estados Unidos como
la Unión Europea están completamente
dispuestos a seguir financiando las
militarmente estratégicamente
burocráticamente los esfuerzos de
Ucrania de pues eh defender su soberanía
sin embargo el punto central de Esta
visita de Úrsula fue Además del tema de
Ucrania el tema energético Y en este
punto pues lo que planteó Úrsula
de la reunión fue precisamente que tan
Europa también estaría dispuesta a
aumentar estos subsidios que le da a las
empresas y lo que dice en ciertos
analistas acá en Washington es que no
quieren entonces entrar en una disputa
de ver qué gobierno o qué grupo de
gobierno se empieza a subvencionar más
las empresas Para no perder precisamente
fuerza de Cara a otros competidores
mucho más grandes Cristóbal Muchísimas
gracias por este reporte desde
Washington
nosotros pasamos a otro de los grandes
temas del día y es que en China el mismo
día Queen revalidó su tercer mandato
presidencial Irán y Arabia Saudita
restablecieron relaciones tras siete
años de ruptura diplomática reunidos en
Beijing en presencia del máximo
diplomático chino wangie representantes
de las dos principales potencias
comunicaron un acuerdo que incluye la
reapertura de embajadas en los
respectivos territorios en un plazo de
dos meses Teherán facciones opuestas en
varios países de Oriente medio como
lleven por ejemplo Así que aseguran que
reactivar su cooperación en materia de
seguridad ayudará a la estabilidad
regional repasemos ahora las relaciones
entre ambas potencias con el siguiente
informe
enero de 2016 read anunció la ruptura de
sus relaciones diplomáticas con Teherán
luego de que manifestantes iraníes
atacaran las misiones diplomáticas
saudíes en Irán tras la ejecución en el
reino de un clérico disidente
el régimen iraní tiene un largo
historial de violaciones contra misiones
diplomáticas extranjeras como la
ocupación de la embajada estadounidense
en 1979 o el ataque a la embajada
británica en 2011 y finalmente ayer el
ataque contra la embajada Saudita entera
y su Consulado General En massad cuál
actividad
esto provocó el estallido de grandes
manifestaciones en Irán y el
empeoramiento de las relaciones entre
ambos países lo que llevó a Teherán a
acusar a Arabia Saudita de
desestabilizar la región y contribuir a
la propagación del terrorismo
el asesinato de esta persona y el
martirio Esta persona es realmente un
crimen es un gran Crimen y aquellos que
toman las decisiones en el gobierno
Saudita no deberían tener ninguna duda
de que esta sangre les causará problemas
la República islámica y el reino de
Arabia Saudita son las dos potencias más
destacadas de la región el más notable
el de yemen donde era una coalición
militar que apoya al gobierno reconocido
internacionalmente
y acusa a Teherán de apoyar a los
sutiles que controlan grandes áreas en
el norte del país sobre todo sana Arabia
Saudita también está preocupada por el
programa nuclear de Irán y sus
capacidades de misiles expresa su
preocupación por la influencia Regional
de Teherán y lo acusa de interferir en
Países Árabes como Irak Siria y Líbano
y cambiamos de información porque el
presidente turcoger firmó el decreto de
convocatoria de elecciones
presidenciales y legislativas con lo que
confirmó que los comicios se celebrarán
según lo previsto el próximo 14 de mayo
selecciones serán cruciales porque
llegan en un momento de horas bajas de
popularidad del actual mandatario en el
poder desde hace 10 años y es que el
país está sumido en una larga crisis
económica y la sociedad mantiene fresco
El recuerdo de los terremotos que
causaron la muerte de más de 52.000
personas a principios de febrero por
otro lado recordemos que el pasado
martes la coalición turca de oposición
presentó ya a su candidato presidencial
se trata del líder de la principal
formación opositora el partido
republicano
para sonar las heridas de nuestros
damnificados por el terremoto para
borrar todo rastro del desastre
Para reconstruir nuestras ciudades Para
volver a incrementar la producción y el
empleo es fundamental que nuestro país
deje atrás cuanto antes la agenda
electoral
este entendimiento y con la autoridad
que nos otorga la Constitución estamos
implementando nuestra decisión
previamente anunciada de llamar a las
elecciones el 14 de mayo en otros temas
el presidente francés y el Primer
Ministro británico acordaron esta mañana
reforzar la cooperación en materia de
control de fronteras energía y apoyo
militar a Ucrania reunidos en el Palacio
del Elíseo macron y sunak dos políticos
provenientes del mundo de las finanzas y
con una línea dura contra la migración
irregular escenificaron un encuentro que
no se producía desde hace cinco años
Durante los cuales las relaciones entre
Londres y París se han visto degradadas
por el brexit o por el acuerdo militar
ocus Alba Santana tiene los detalles
es una nueva era en las relaciones entre
Francia y Reino Unido así lo definieron
el presidente de Francia Emanuel mazcon
y el Primer Ministro de Reino Unido
Richi sunak y
es un momento yo diría de reencuentro
reconexión y nuevo comienzo marca una
voluntad común de hablar entre nosotros
de coordinarnos mejor y de construir
juntos nuevas perspectivas
y es que en esta Cumbre que reunió a
empresarios importantes de ambos lados
del Canal de la Mancha los países
relanzaron sus relaciones bilaterales
tras años de roces debido al brexit con
el problema del protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte solucionado y la Guerra de Ucrania
de fondo Reino Unido y Francia tienen
muchos intereses en común entre estos la
migración o más bien cómo frenar la
llegada irregular de migrantes a las
costas británicas después de registrar a
más de 45.000 personas en 2022 para lo
que Londres pagará 577 millones millones
de dólares a París
hoy hemos llevado a nuestra cooperación
a un nivel sin precedentes para hacer
frente a un desafío compartido
anunciamos un nuevo centro de detención
en el norte de Francia un nuevo centro
de mando que reunirá por primera vez a
nuestros equipos encargados de hacer
cumplir la ley
otro de los grandes anuncios fue un
pacto nuclear de cooperación civil y en
materia de defensa que entrenarán a
Marines ucranianos coordinarán sus
portaaviones en el lindo Pacífico y
cooperarán en desarrollo armamentístico
en la cop 27 de Egipto Solo dos semanas
después de que sunak juramentara ya se
vio cercanía entre los mandatarios algo
que algunos tabloides británicos
llegaron a catalogar como lebromans Y
esta es la primera reunión de las
Naciones miembros permanentes del
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU y ambas
potencias nucleares en cinco años
y cerramos en Alemania porque la policía
alemana confirmó la detención de un
hombre sospechoso de tener retenido a un
grupo de Rehenes en la entrada de un
edificio en Carl ruge en el sur del país
la situación se resolvió sin heridos
según las autoridades pero recordemos
que esta noche en la ciudad alemana de
Hamburgo en el norte del país un hombre
mató a siete personas en un tiroteo
masivo en un centro de Testigos de
Jehová y que después de perpetrar el
ataque el agresor se quitó la vida a
estas horas continúan Las
investigaciones para determinar el móvil
del crimen
digamos así al final de esta emisión
pero sigan con nosotros en France 24
punto com
[Música]